[Música]
hola qué tal les habla pablo gómez
barrios y bienvenidos a esta emisión de
este fin de semana 12 de abril 12 13 y
14 de abril que estoy acá en estudio
acompañado esta tarde por leonor a
chapman gala nardo que menos paloma
martínez y tenemos una invitada ella es
en acertar y gutiérrez bienvenidos a
todos también ha vuelto después del acto
se ha logrado escapar por aquí tengo de
hecho mi arma mi arma
hoy es un traficante de bacilos bueno
estoy escuchando que han a ver las
américas café o el castor cibernético
como lo llamamos cariñosamente
este programa es transmitido en directo
por facebook live youtube y en nuestro
sitio internet
rcn punto y en la aplicación y en la
aplicación de rci radio canadá
internacional en español así de que no
son los medios los que les faltaría para
que no se escucharan solo la intención
de encontrarnos sólo faltan los
micrófonos y el estudio de radio que nos
reencontremos y ahora estamos acá en una
especie de híbrido entre la televisión
la web y bien entonces pero estamos
viviendo con los adelantos de nuestra
época no claro
como unos adelantados los adelantados
bueno un caluroso saludo a todos ustedes
allá del otro lado de la cámara y del
micrófono les decíamos que tenemos una
invitada en ofertar y gutiérrez ella es
maestra en el grupo folclórico mexicano
los pequeños de la piel y esto es nadie
lee exactamente de ok y contigo vamos a
conversar más tarde sobre este proyecto
bienvenido a muchísimas gracias por
recibirme y antes de internar nos en las
profundidades
de profundidad de aguas
imagínate pero bueno vamos a comenzar
con alguna noticia que ustedes quieran
darle seguimiento o algo inédito que
haya sucedido y que les haya atraído la
atención entonces en el caso tuyo
leonora ya todos sabemos lo que pasó
esta semana con julian assange el
fundador de wikileaks alguien que estaba
refugiado en la embajada de ecuador en
londres y hubo algo que atrajo su
atención y que despertó su interés con
respecto a wikileaks y canadá sí
exactamente que me causó una gran
desilusión de eso decía la gran
desilusión random esa estábamos hablando
es que hubo revelaciones de wikileaks
que conciernen a canadá y que yo
personalmente no estaba al tanto pero
hubo esta información hace tiempo
limitada tal vez y que fue publicada hoy
por la policía
la red pública canadiense del
radiodifusor público canadienses y
visible radio canadá en la cual publican
ellos 9 noticias difundidas por
wikileaks sobre canadá y a mí me
llamaron la atención tres de las cuales
puedo a ver rápidamente de 2
una es si todos recuerdan el año 2003 un
17 de marzo dos días antes que se
bombardee que eeuu volver de bagdad el
primer ministro de la época ya cristian
frente al parlamento había dicho que
canadá no participaría en esta guerra si
no fuera un llamado de una coalición de
naciones unidas en este caso era
solamente eeuu con inglaterra y otros 23
países y entonces hubo pues una especie
yo puedo decir de orgullo nacional
canadiense ante la posición de jan
christian lo pueden ver la foto ahí en
el parlamento felicitado por todo el
mundo se negó categóricamente a ir a la
guerra con eeuu algo que después
wikileaks pública que en el mismo día
que ya cristian rechazaba firme y
públicamente la petición de eeuu de
unirse a la invasión a irak
canadá prometió apoyo militar
clandestino para esa operación en
washington entonces vinieron de
funcionarios de eeuu de inglaterra y se
reunieron aquí con canadienses entonces
fue una guerra un poco escondida en la
cual participó y sin embargo esto es
algo que se sabe muy poco y el segundo
hecho tiene que ver con otro ex primer
ministro canadiense esta vez conservador
que es stephen stephen harper que había
digamos hecho de la defensa del ártico
canadiense su caballito de batalla
también orgullo nacional canadiense
entonces pudimos ver durante su mandato
que fue varias veces al ártico a decir
que bueno había había que protegerlo
justamente de rusia y de otros países
porque había que delimitar en la zona
canadiense etcétera etcétera lo que dice
un informe ahí que salió de wikileaks es
que
eeuu no consideraba en serio lo que
decía stephen harper sobre la soberanía
del ártico canadiense más bien decía que
lo que hacía harper era como dar golpes
en el vacío con el solo objetivo de
ganar votos en las elecciones siguientes
lo cual yo no quiero decir que eso sea
verdad de parte de stephen harper eso es
la interpretación de eeuu que rara vez
se equivocan también los estadounidenses
pero discurso y acto digamos por un lado
porque aunque fue varias veces al ártico
lo que sí se sabe es que eso le dio
votos a harper en las elecciones
siguientes entonces son revelaciones de
wikileaks después hay una tercera que la
gente pudiera ver en el sitio web que
tiene que ver con montreal el metro de
montreal y amenazas de bombas es después
de los eventos del año 2001
unos años más tarde en montreal y que
fue aprovechado esa supuesta amenaza de
bomba para que eeuu se sintiera
amenazado en canadá porque la amenaza
era a la embajada estadounidense en
ottawa cosa que eeuu aproveché
y le pidió a canadá que reforzará la
seguridad en todos los organismos
estadounidenses en canadá en todas las
provincias entonces incluyendo radio
canadá
a block sí pero hablo de ciprodeh
instalaciones estadounidense esta
embajada económicos y de seguridad
después de la guerra pero esta es la
historia específicamente con eeuu y que
aquí dice que solicitar un aumento de la
seguridad en halifax montreal toronto
winnipeg calgary vancouver y la ciudad
de quebec y ottawa es decir todo el país
y canadá lo hizo entonces hay que tener
cuidado con esas esas noticias gato
encerrado
de esa supuesta amenaza de una bomba
finalmente si vice por ejemplo se niega
a publicar el nombre de esa supuesta
persona que amenazó que era un tunecino
que estaba en canadá hace cinco años y
que aparentemente no tenían nada que ver
y tampoco había una gran amenaza de
bomba como adición en la época entonces
que sí jugó ahí no se sabe pero esta es
información de wikileaks bueno entonces
sí entonces eso me sorprendió
bueno esto un leonardo gimeno que tengo
con una sonrisa
recordar justamente lo que vamos a
hablar con una locura generalizada
deseado
y es una de las cosas que el francés le
cambia el nombre a la guerra no el trono
de hierro por favor en todo el mundo se
llama que mostró un juego de tronos
[Risas]
y le ponemos el trono de vida
y lo que contaba leonor de los wikileaks
y de estas cosas y que como se tapa uno
como se tapa otro es exactamente esto
esto el juego de tronos de eso se trata
de una locura generalizada porque la
octava temporada y última que consta de
seis capítulos dijo que la última en
vivo y en directo
avance de esta última temporada que
empieza el domingo el domingo próximo
a las 9 de la noche a caramba se nota
que esos fanáticos
en realidad no es una gran maratón
porque admite originaba no me gusta no
me gusta nos gustaría pérez pérez pérez
invitó en un mail
es realmente espectacular
cuando empezaron muchos de ellos eran
niños dos años cuando la primera
temporada recién veía con una
recapitulación buscando un vídeo para
mostrarles ustedes este es el de la
promoción de la última temporada pero en
la recapitulación salía
la niña está que acaba para hacer que es
uno de los personajes que interpreta
aquí ya tenía ocho años
claro y ahora es 1820
[Música]
[Risas]
disfrazado por las calles
están donde la gente se pudiera sacar
fotos con él con el trono de hierro
realmente una cosa especial que está
pasando y no pasa con muchas es de
televisión y está en realidad es un
efecto super especial porque son 10 años
10 años de 10 continúan continuamente
esta serie ahí en la palestra y ahora
con este cierre fantástico
y bueno vamos a ver quién es el que se
corona y yo le quiero preguntar a
nuestros oyentes allá del otro lado
están del otro lado de la pantalla y del
micrófono como decíamos cuando teníamos
el micrófono delante
que piensan es que lo que leonardo está
contando acá y de esa locura que ha
invadido aquí en montreal
la luz aficionados en américa
vamos a ver qué pasa en realidad no sé
la gente empieza a saludar luis balderas
dice saludos de san antonio en chile
catherine no se salvan se burla de
saludos desde p
[Música]
javier gonzález nunca dice sra
- pablo barrios paloma martínez e
invitados saludos un abrazo desde
guadalajara méxico
formato el programa y el estudio me
parecen muy buenos dice así que no hay
mucho que hago de cargar yo dice buenos
y javier gonzález también dice ay caray
se me olvida de paloma mil disculpas y
maría herrera y se feliz de compartir
semanalmente vuestro programa saludos a
todos desde san luis argentina saludos
entonces para todos los que están
sintonizando díaz saludos amigos desde
ecuador otro beso no no si tiene éxito
también
más la gran promoción para américa
latina si son méxico y en nuestro sitio
internet música del norte pero estamos
en américa latina' igual
la latina mente compartido el idioma
digamos y en el sitio yo puse una foto
en el sector de abajo de nuestro sitio
internet donde ponemos foto de lo que
pasa en el mundo pues una foto de la
promoción de game of thrones en mexico y
sale
en el trono y la gente que se puede
sentar sacarse fotos del trono
hay un mexicano que está ahí sacando su
nación
bueno entonces esa es la locura de el
juego de tronos díganos ustedes allá de
cómo está pasando eso en sus países
mientras tanto paloma si al parecer al
parecer facebook promete un algoritmo
para detectar a los usuarios que han
muerto exacta porque siguen viviendo
muchas personas conozco personalmente a
alguien que sigue viviendo en facebook
pero ya desapareció ella murió desde
hace cuatro años suena medio medio loco
pero yo le sigo mandando saludos un
amigo hace ocho años en facebook aunque
yo le mando saludos nadie me contesta
pero los saludos están miralo
bueno pues exactamente pablo facebook
prometió que este martes de esta semana
respetar mejor el duelo de las familias
de personas que han muerto y que tenían
una muy perfil en facebook porque con un
nuevo algoritmo con inteligencia
artificial se abstendrán ahora de enviar
notificaciones recordatorios de
cumpleaños a los amigos de facebook de
un usuario
fallecido entonces dicen que van a ser
un poco más respetuosos de eso porque
hasta el momento no podían detectar el
nuevo algoritmo de facebook va a
detectar es ya mí yo no sé nada de
nuevas tecnologías que no me pareció
particular y me pareció curioso digamos
para empezar el programa a hablar de
esta nueva inteligencia una persona
clara que nos la familia no declara que
está muerto no exactamente es lo que va
a ser el algoritmo lo que se va a dar
cuenta es que no está no está publicando
nada y por sports inteligencia
artificial
dos años que no publicó nada en facebook
pero nadie ha dicho nada de ti en
facebook como que falles ist entonces
primero lo conociste
desde la inteligencia artificial y el
algoritmo de la familia a otro familiar
uno puede borrar la cuenta de facebook
si uno uno uno puede en realidad
facebook permite poner como un apoderado
de la cuenta
apoderado se queda ahí es decir que yo
puedo decir mi hijo se va a hacer cargo
de mi cuenta
porque no me quieres morir como un
testamento la mayoría de la gente triste
esto va para mis hijos pero no dejo el
testamento porque no creo que me voy a
morir los 20 entonces bueno la idea es
que este algoritmo y tú no lo explicará
en una crónica más alargada un día
porque es interesante toda la tecnología
detrás pero lo que van y desea detectar
si hay gente que mencionó el nombre de
esta persona que no ha no ha tenido
ninguna actividad en facebook durante
cierto tiempo y entonces detectar si
alguien dijo que ya se murió de falsas
noticias
hace un par de años yo había publicado
en la crónica de tecnología un algoritmo
no de inteligencia artificial pues no
estaba tan desarrollo en ese momento
pero era
de twitter que uno pagaba una aplicación
y esa aplicación aprendía como nosotros
tuitea vamos y cuando uno se moría esa
aplicación continua continuado
habilitando al estilo que yo lo hice
durante mi vida como para mantener la
apreciación
en algún momento esas nuevas tecnologías
van a tomar y ocupar los lugares de los
seres humanos y nosotros van a convertir
en esclavos espero que no hay algo más
fred echeverría ese salido saludos desde
ecuador es la fiebre mediática es
mundial
supongo que estamos hablando del juego
de los tronos como lo es la noticia
mundial en ecuador en estos momentos
felices y también saludos desde melo
cerro largo uruguay es gustavo lucas que
también
muy bien y bueno por mi parte a mí lo
que me pareció curioso a esta semana es
que
hay un señor de new brunswick que hace
dos semanas ganó por la decimonovena vez
la medalla de oro en pulseo impulsión
que estábamos fuego después el juego de
fuerzas y el brazo de fuerza de brazos
exactos y que con leonardo estábamos
tratando porque en algunos lugares le
dice pulso hacer un pulso en otros
lugares dicen pulseada tú decides echar
una pulseada en fin no es nada fácil
poderse
dirigir correctamente en todos esos
términos pero este señor lo interesante
es que él
explica no como como cómo se prepara
para esos campeonatos y lo que me
pareció que hay campeonatos locales
regionales
provinciales canadienses y hace un
torneo mundial
ha ganado el mundial pero se está
preparando para el torneo mundial que se
va a llevar a cabo del 26 de octubre al
4 de noviembre en rumanía constan me
acuerdo en realidad de la película se
acuerdan de la película no cobraran
stallone esta lógica
él también estaba pulsando para
recuperar a su hijo
y en ese momento yo me enteré que había
competiciones internacionales no
competencias internacionales
muy buenos en eso son campeones del
mundo
pero sabes que él decía y eso me
sorprendió también que un combate dura
fracciones de segundo un segundo máximo
y cuando muy largo dos segundos pero si
eso se arregla y estuve viendo algunos
vídeos justamente y verdaderamente se
pone en ese curso
[Risas]
además es que este señor es un
maratonista consumado y al mismo tiempo
que se ha consumido para torneos y él va
a correr el 12 de mayo próximo el
maratón de new brunswick en fredericton
y el 19 de mayo el maratón de sugar love
en el estado de maine en marítima entre
maratón y maratón hace pulsera y ya está
jubilado
en la escuela secundaria creo en verdura
para el pulseo porque tú maratonista
eres mi meta es ganarle al señor de
nuevo brote
bueno pues si entonces dentro de eso
dentro de los temas que llamaron nuestra
atención esta semana y como ya les
habíamos dicho al principio tenemos una
invitada a quien estudio ella se llama
nefertari gutiérrez necesario y
nuevamente bienvenida muchísimas gracias
por decir más y tú estás acá porque nos
vas a hablar de un proyecto en
particular se llama los pequeños de de
nayeli de un área para la información
del público nadie lee significa amor te
amo te quiero en la lengua zapoteca del
este de méxico más particularmente del
estado de oaxaca entonces pues si somos
un grupo de folklore mexicano de danza
folklórica mexicana que estamos aquí
desde 1990 después de que una
quebequense de aquí fundó el grupo de
los pequeños de angeli
bueno el proyecto ahorita que se acerca
no es el día de los niños y saben
nosotros en méxico festejamos el edén y
el 30 de abril en este caso pues está en
tres semanas y que van a estar
festejando con los pequeños de nayeli el
día del niño
aquí en montreal en el 25 15 calle de
lille entonces también invitados a ver
piñata a ver danza folklórica los
esperamos un evento familiar de 12 a 5
de la tarde nosotros igual nosotros como
no hay el día niño en canadá
mis hijos toman
como hemos hecho una suplantación del
día del niño que no se festeja en canadá
que me acuerdo en argentina nos hace una
cuestión comercial
la festejamos de la madre del padre de
los abuelos
de los muertos exactamente entonces en
verdad es para toda la comunidad
latinoamericana no sólo para mexicanos
así que están invitados todos como les
digo a ver danza piñatas que eso sí es
súper conocido ya incluso aquí entonces
los esperamos a todos y si no si les
interesa mucho más de la danza
folklórica también el 2 de junio domingo
vamos a tener nuestro show de fin de año
va a ser pura danza desde nuestros
pequeños de tres años hasta nuestro
ballet nayeli se va a estar presentando
en el colegio ya que nos pueden seguir
también en facebook que obviamente como
estamos hablando de las tecnologías
pajín a los pequeños de nayeli hoy
también esperamos la escuela son hijos
de mexicanos y no sólo tenemos que
pienses tenemos de verdad que
salvadoreños es es verdad es una
comunidad abierta a preservar nuestra
diversa de preservar nuestra lengua
nuestras culturas
y también una actividad para los niños
para nos lo tenemos bueno yo llegué
joven no tenía tanto la oportunidad de
hablar español más que en mi casa y
éramos tres en la casa entonces no había
tanta oportunidad entonces esto crean
amistades para
en español nosotros en argentina nuestro
folklore argentino es bueno
la samba la chacarera el gato el gato
cool ya no son distintos estilos iguales
el folclore mexicano el folklore
mexicano en sí es una mezcla de los
pueblos originarios los pueblos
indígenas con los españoles que llegaron
entonces hay muchos zapateado como
justamente el argentino
muchos zapateado y muchos faldeo también
entonces las las faldas que usaban hace
tiempo en que eran largas y robustas eso
usamos obviamente depende nosotros no es
tanto por el estilo sino el estado en el
que estás como méxico es tan grande tan
diverso hay de todo ahí ponerlo en
veracruz que es al sur de méxico y hace
mucho calor es en la costa pues las
mujeres van a usar vestidos de mando
livianos blancos para no atraer tanto el
calor van a andar con su abanico exacto
entonces más al norte pues van a usar
más botas en vez de zapatos botas van a
usar faldas cortas entonces va a
depender mucho
es el zapateado hay en todos apartado
hay en todos los instrumentos en los
instrumentos también dependen de el
estado comprende el norte va a ser más
banda tómense instrumentos de viento y
el mariachi también de jalisco en el
norte y más trabajo hacer el cajón que
se usa también en los países por ejemplo
como perú el cajón es de las jaranas
como veracruz y el arpa
[Música]
[Risas]
este organismo fue creado en los años
900 90 90 por una que beckham seis son
tales y es aquí quien se sigue estando
ahí no ya no compro somos una ong
entonces tenemos un consejo de
administración qué tipo de actividades
realizan aparte de enseñar danza a los
niños lo principal es la danza de ahí en
fuera como les digo es preservar todas
las
es una vez por semana la mayoría una
hora y 15 nos reunimos por el momento es
en un local se llama ya estudio ahí nos
reunimos una hora 15 estamos preparando
justamente el show de fin de año para
gente que ya tiene experiencia tenemos
el ballet nayeli que yo si se presentan
pueden suspender bar para bodas para
festivales es que salen de montreal
también para que así hemos salido de
montar otros festivales actos por
ejemplo en london ontario que había sido
hay un festival como tres veces cada dos
años en este festival
entonces si hemos tenido la oportunidad
de salir de montar vamos a conocer un
poquito más hubo un desfile las el año
pasado y otros años iremos cubierto aquí
el desfile de las am de la ministra
nuestro administrará la cena
participaron ahí no no hemos tenido la
oportunidad pero tal vez están los
proyectos porque ahí se presentan
ballets folclóricos de de toda
latinoamérica de toda américa latina yo
vi de bolivia de colores y vernos zilina
y ahí vélez folclórico
bien había uno de méxico parís y en
méxico somos más unos 34 grupos de
folklore exacto entonces nos dividimos
un poquito en la isla de montaña pero si
además me parece muy interesante lo que
hacen porque yo conozco por ejemplo el
caso argentino
y hay argentinos que realmente quieren
que los niños aprendan el castellano que
no lo pierdan por vivir aquí entonces
dan cursos de castellano los sábados
pero hacerlo con la danza también tiene
otra connotación es decir dos pájaros se
matan es aprender de sus culturas
ejemplo es decir haber niños vamos a
montar la danza azteca quienes quieren a
los aztecas a donde vivían que tienen
que nos aportan cuál es nuestra relación
hacia ellos o por ejemplo bueno cuáles
son los estados de méxico cuál está el
norte cual está sur es en verdad toda la
cultura porque en sí el baile es muy muy
cultural
a partir de los tres años que puedan
caminar ya en el interior del grupo un
ofertar y se colectó ocupación que así
yo ahorita estoy maestra y coreógrafa
del grupo de adolescentes de 12 a 18
años y del grupo de adultos de 18 años
en adelante normalmente son la es una
actividad familiar en sí por ejemplo al
mismo tiempo que estoy dando la
las mamás pues una compañera tiene a sus
chiquitos entonces en verdad todos se
pueden incluir y si no en el pasado
también fui bailarina de ballet solo por
cuestiones de tiempo ya ya no no puedo
hacer todo entonces preferí tomar esta
aventura de ahora enseñar y que se
contiene esta esa tradición bueno pues
les deseamos mucho éxito el 28 de abril
el día del niño y el 2 de junio en
nuestro show de fin de año en el colegio
rafael nos pueden seguir también como
les dije en las redes sociales facebook
los pequeños de nadie
y me faltaría muchísimas gracias por
haber aceptado la invitación
[Risas]
tenemos a comentar
dice creo que el tío sam estamos
hablando de la historia de wikileaks y
si no le gustó que se le cuente lo que
pasa en guantánamo y en todas las ayudas
humanitarias democráticas del mismo
entonces bueno es como hablando
comentarios con respecto a la historia
wikileaks y vladimir rodríguez dice
saludos desde estelí nicaragua se les
aprecia buen programa es muy bien y
bueno ahora vamos a hablar un poco de
nuestra aplicación
y que se me olvidó en la presentación de
hablar de la aplicación y que ese es uno
del ayto campo preferido o mi querido
leonardo si a mí el campo me gusta más
en verano pero bueno la aplicación la
pueden bajar desde las dos grandes
tiendas
android para
el iphone
en realidad lo que hace es a un solo
clic tener toda la información que
ustedes pueden tener ya en el sitio de
internet que también es responsivo es
decir que funciona cuando uno entra
desde el teléfono pero aplicación está
mucho más condensada y tiene la
posibilidad de recorrer la información
de una manera muy fácil muy amena y muy
rápida y tiene la particularidad de que
uno puede guardar por ejemplo si alguno
le gustó un artículo particular y no
tuvo tiempo de leerlo lo guardo lole
después ese tipo de cosas que en
realidad en el sitio interna en el sitio
internet no se puede y facilita
convencer ahora la edad y el acceso a la
información es así que por lo
recomendado radio canal internacional en
español está en las cinco lenguas en
español tiene el francés y el inglés
asociados por son las lenguas oficiales
igual que en las otras dos lenguas
extraoficiales
habla árabe y mandarín y cuando uno baja
la aplicación en
el francés tiene inglés español cuando
la baja en inglés tiene en francés
español y podemos escuchar este programa
fue agregado después tiene que hacer la
gente si tú tienes tu teléfono tu
aplicación para ir a buscar el programa
como lo buscan porque no lo hago yo
porque normalmente estoy en el programa
y ahora lo vamos a buscar donde se dice
francés vídeos vídeos vídeo manda tour y
canadá
[Risas]
si no funciona pero estuvimos viendo
pero no lo encuentro
se llama mande a un colega con los
dragones de que esto es bueno y vamos
entonces el tiempo está pasando muy
rápidamente nos quedan 26 minutos
más rápido imposible ya lo tienes en la
en la aplicación entra en las tres
rayitas que están aquí arriba a la
derecha a la izquierda y anna villar
llegada arriba ya la izquierda y dice
nuestros programas en vídeo cuando uno
hace nuestros programas en vídeo aparece
y haití que está este programa en este
momento el que se dé vuelta
la vuelta está ahí estás viendo ahí
están viendo a pablo ahí están viendo me
a mí hablando de esto
ese es el programa sí
[Música]
mostrándome a mí cuando me vea después
va a ser el problema de la vida de la
ubicuidad bueno muy bien entonces como
decíamos el tiempo pasa muy rápido vamos
a entrar de lleno con los temas que
queremos resaltar esta semana y leonora
tú conversas test con rosa ballesteros
que es una joven colombiana comprometida
con la paz en colombia
si ella estuvo acá de paso de visita en
ottawa y en montreal en el marco de la
presentación de un informe de una
investigación realizada por naciones
unidas hace dos años sobre la juventud
en el mundo la seguridad y la paz y uno
de los 25 países que participaron de
esta investigación de naciones unidas
fue colombia entonces ella vino a ottawa
ella es la voy a presentar esa activista
colombiana directora de proyectos de
tierra libre y está asociada con oxfam
québec que también trabaja en colombia
en el proyecto
con el organismo tierra libre es un
organismo que defiende los derechos
humanos el medio ambiente y las minorías
fue una conversación muy interesante
ella fue a ottawa junto con opción a
presentar los resultados de esta
investigación de naciones unidas y
estuvimos conversando mucho sobre todo
el tema que a mí me interesaba
particularmente que era la juventud en
colombia la política la paz tiene dijo
cosas muy muy interesantes que viene de
una veinteañera que entonces por ejemplo
ella dijo y lo leo lo recalca en el
reportaje cuando después dice de que
sucedió el plebiscito en el mes de
noviembre donde lamentablemente colombia
perdió se le visitó los que estaban por
la paz lo perdieron ella dice quienes
salieron a movilizarse fueron los
jóvenes solo en la ciudad de bogotá se
movilizaron más de 30.000 jóvenes y esas
movilizaciones ocurrieron en todas las
ciudades del país y después dijo algo
muy interesante y que viene un poco
contrario a lo que sucedía en los años
70 en américa latina y en el mundo en
algunos lugares ella dice nosotros los
jóvenes consideramos que no es posible
continuar con los escenarios de guerra
como es colombia todos sabemos que vivió
periodo 2 pablos solo sabes
exacto naciste con la guerra y lo que
ella dices no es posible eliminar un
conflicto no es posible terminar con un
conflicto eliminando al adversario no
tiene sentido cuando ese era un poco la
violencia también que había en años
anteriores entonces lo que ella dice una
salida política negociada entonces y
bueno y en ese tiene ese en esa
conversación que tuvimos también destaca
la juventud colombiana que es muy
democrática muy abierta muy en búsqueda
de soluciones habla de las necesidades
de los jóvenes y por qué tienen que ser
escuchados y cada vez más en colombia
entre otras cosas me pareció una líder
que realmente es una líder una joven
líder desde los tiempos presentes y
futuros en colombia
y lo que quieren tener más detalles
sobre esta entrevista de leonora chapman
con rózsa ballesteros pueden visitar
nuestro sitio internet
rcn t.co la aplicación ahí en la
aplicación encontrará muy fácilmente el
reportaje
de pasar otra cosa mensaje que es esa
rodilla chávez y saludos
desde bogotá y se ha perdido la
aplicación es un fenómeno muy bueno
recomendado también para bajarla pueden
ir a nuestro sitio está a la derecha
arriba al y térmicas a la derecha del
pósito arriba está la aplicación de la
pantalla por la derecha el sitio
está la publicidad de la aplicación
hacen clic y ahí tienen los vínculos
para ir a cualquiera de los dos lugares
y yo quisiera aprovechar que tenemos acá
cautivo a nuestro público para
invitarlos a que participen así en este
programa además de los comentarios que
nos hacen durante el programa nos pueden
enviar también pequeños vidrios sobre lo
que es su barrio lo que ustedes quieran
lo que le llamé la atención un pequeño
vídeo unos 30 segundos por ahí 45
segundos y lo nosotros lo pasamos acá al
mismo tiempo le permite a todos nos
permite a todos ver conocer el lugar
desde donde ellos nos están escuchando
se pueden ver con cara de pino lo que
pasa es que se pueden mandar videos y
vídeos también
cualquier adiós como pablo o videos como
nosotros
nosotros como nosotros la invitación
está hecha paloma martínez y nos hablas
de un proyecto canadiense que busca
recuperar nada más y nada menos que la
memoria de sobrevivientes de masacres en
el salvador un proyecto de 30 que me
pareció maravilloso porque es una un
grupo de investigadores en canadá pero
también están asociados con otros
investigadores en bélgica
particularmente fueron a recuperar
fotografías principalmente comenzó con
ir a recuperar fotografías de
trabajadores humanitarios de gente que
hubiera estado en el salvador en esa
época en la época de la guerra civil
civil salvadoreña entonces lo que
quisieron fue recuperar todas las
fotografías armaron
un colectivo con esa gente que estaba
interesada en el tema y con las
fotografías e ir al salvador a buscar a
la gente que había estado en los campos
de refugiados que habían sido instalados
por la onu en honduras donde habían
estado esta gente y donde los
trabajadores humanitarios les habían
ayudado a sobrevivir digamos a las
masacres a la guerra civil como tal en
el salvador entonces fueron a buscar a
la gente que eran que había vivido en
esos campos de refugiados les mostraron
las fotografías y comenzaron a hacer
talleres con ellos los talleres implican
salud mental implican también recuperar
justamente la tristeza pero también
hablarles de la resiliencia que es la
fuerza con la que ellos salieron
adelante
después de estas masacres y estas
terribles pérdidas dentro de las
familias que fueron a visitar entonces
recuperar ese también fueron a buscar
música la música que fue parte de la
sobrevivencia en los campos de
refugiados de salvadoreños en honduras
porque había músicos que que mucha gente
identificó como
a aquellos que les trajeron la felicidad
digamos cuando todo iba mal entonces muy
bonito proyecto llevado a cabo entre
otras personas por la canadiense que ya
lo montó el pro llegó la canadiense
amanda grit y un grupo muy un equipo
multidisciplinario y multinacional
también pero principalmente los
investigadores son canadienses de origen
latinoamericano y no una mezcla y todos
son de la universidad western ontario
que armaron este proyecto y en el sitio
internet les tip les titulamos esto con
fotos mapas y música porque también
están cartografiando están
cartografiando los diferentes lugares
donde las masacres tuvieron lugar para
justamente recuperar la memoria que se
perdió con la gente que murió también es
muy interesante rcn puntos y ahí en
nuestra aplicación y en todas nuestras
plataformas pueden consultar los
reportajes y entrevistas que hacemos
aquí a diario en radio canadá
internacional itu leonardo que menos tú
nos hablas de cambios en los algoritmos
facebook pero esta vez para
contrarrestar las falsas noticias así
esbelto en el año 2018 había habido un
cambio grande en el algoritmo de las
noticias del news feed de la agregación
de noticias de facebook que bueno no nos
benefició a nosotros como medio de
comunicación porque lo que hizo fue
evitar que todas las noticias de los
grandes medios pasarán por el fin de
información o sea uno tenía que
afiliarse o ir a buscar ese tipo de
información en este caso lo que va a
hacer es cambiar el algoritmo pero no
para la agregación de noticias
como tal sino para evitar que la afe
news entren en esta cuestión de la
agregación de contenidos y el tema es
que facebook tiene varios problemas en
este sentido hay mucha gente que está en
contra de qué
hay algoritmos que están hechos desde el
otro lado para justamente hacer que las
noticias de estas falsas entren y la
gente las comparta buscan viralizar la
noticia y eso efectivamente pasa y pasa
en un lugar muy puntual que es en los
grupos de facebook y los grupos pueden
ser abiertos semis cerrados o cerrados y
el problema es que en estos grupos
cerrados facebook no tiene mucha
injerencia entonces no tiene acceso de
sí pero no puede por digamos cómo está
planteada la cosa no puede meterse
abiertamente eso tiene que entrar en
contacto con los administradores y en
realidad ofrecer como la posibilidad de
cambiarlos si no lo cambia no no no la
web profunda es absolutamente de otra
cosa esto es solamente un grupo cerrado
y es más complejo pero facebook ha dicho
lo vamos a hacer así que ha cambiado
nuevamente para identificar primero como
base identificar la noticia falsa y
después poder lograr evitar que esto
me fundí funda con locura y se haga
viral como está pasando ahora bueno muy
bien entonces muchas gracias rs ineter
punto o sea como siempre y antes de que
se me olvide yo quiero agradecer hoy a
nuestros técnicos en los controles
técnicos allá del otro lado ven un gran
marc andrey de sión y piernas til que
son los responsables de que ustedes allá
nos extendiendo bueno muy rápidamente yo
les diré que yo hice una entrevista con
manuel vázquez valdés que es secretario
académico de la unam canadá y la semana
pasada el grupo de teatro de la unam a
aquí en canadá presentó la obra de
teatro mujeres de arena testimonios de
mujeres en ciudad juárez entonces fuese
una entrevista interesante y una obra de
teatro todavía más interesante así que
yo los invito a que vayan a escuchar eso
en nuestro sitio
internet r6 net punto sea y eso fue todo
desafortunadamente el tiempo del que
disponíamos para
este programa adiós